herma still hasn't reached the United
States mainland but hundreds of miles
away in North Florida the Jacksonville
area is under hurricane warning hundreds
of thousands of people have been told to
evacuate the Rica Duncan is in Atlantic
Beach outside of Jacksonville with the
concern about dangerous winds and storm
surge that will start tonight
Jericka good morning good morning the
wind is really picking up here here off
the coast of Jacksonville you can even
see the waves behind me that are very
powerful
excuse me about putting my head down
because those granules of sand are
literally pelting me in the face but
since we've been out here this morning
again the concern is for people at this
point who are still here to stay inside
we have seen a couple of people that
have actually been out on the beach
despite the warnings that they should
not be out here despite the fact that
there have been mandatory evacuations
since yesterday the police chief told me
the concern really is the fact that once
the winds sustained at 40 miles per hour
they are shutting down the bridges
that's important because that's the only
access to any major hospital I asked the
police chief what do you do then if you
have emergencies she said I don't know
we'll have to figure that out in the
moment she also said her biggest fear is
having to give death certificates to
families because people chose to stay
and didn't take it as seriously because
we are on the East Coast at the end of
the day this is still a hurricane Nora
Wow Jericka Duncan with that ferries a
scary sobering thought yeah that's our
biggest concern is knowing that you will
probably give death certificates because
some people despite all the warnings
just say that they're not leaving I
don't understand that my sister included
I don't get it I don't get it